مساء الخير في مؤتمر اتحاد البرلمان
العربي مؤخرا اعترض الثلاث الدول العربيه
وهي الامارات والسعوديه ومصر على ادراك
حضر التطبيع مع اسرائيل في البيان الختامي
للمؤتمر الامر اللي بيقدر مره ثانيه
حساسيه او مازق دول الخليج في التطبيع مع
اسرائيل
هي لدول الخليج تطبع وليه في مازق قبل ما
قلته بالاسباب اللي ب يدعوها لل حماس
الشديد جدا الى اسرائيل هو لازم نوضح
المقصود دول الخليج دول الخليج تعريفه لها
الخمس دول باستثناء الكويت الكويت فيما
اعلم خطا اقرب الى الموقف العربي التقليدي
اللي كان رافض او ال غير متحمس لاقامه
علاقات ساخره مع اسرائيل قبل التسويه كل
القضايا العالقه فيما يتعلق بالدول الخمسه
القاسم المشترك رغم وجود اختلافات بينها
بينهم على الدوافع والاهداف والسياسات لكن
القاسم المشترك انهم متحمسين لاقامه
علاقات مع اسرائيل
حدثنا النهار ده اللي هي الدوافع خصوصا
بالنسبه ل السعوديه والبحرين
والامارات الحقيقه انه في ثلاث اسباب
رئيسيه تدفع كل هذه الدول لاقامه علاقات
ساخنه مع اسرائيل السبب الاول ان ي
انه بعد
ثورات الربيع العربي او ما يسمى بثورات
الربيع العربي هذه الدول وجدت نفسها في
الواقع الجديد الواقع الجديد بيقول ايه
انه قدمها تحديين رئيسيين تحدي الاولاني
قادم من ايران والاتحاد الثاني القادم بين
جماعات الاسلام السياسي اذا كانت جماعات
توصل الحكم بالانتخابات في جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين او جماعات عاوزه توصل الى الحكم
بقوه السلاح في داعش والنصره
وصلت الفروض تمثل مشهد يعني مهم جدا لشرح
الخطر اللي دول الخليج ال متصوره انه
بيحبها من كل مكان في السنه دي كانت في اه
احداث او انتفاضات موجوده في البحرين من
المواطنين الشيعه هناك ودول الخليج تعتقد
ان ايران المحرك الاساسي اليوم الخطر
الايراني
اللي طبعا بعد كدا تمدد فيه اعتمدت قبل
ذلك وبعد ذلك في العراق وسوريا واليمن
ولبنان ودول اخرى وفي نفس العام 2012 كان
في اه احتجاجات واسعه جدا شارك فيها
الالاف ضخمه في الكويت
ووقتها اتهمت السعوديه والامارات والدول
الاخرى جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بمحاوله
تغيير النظام في الخليج بدايه من الكويت
السنديك بتمثل كده الخطر الايراني والخطر
جماعات الاسلام السياسي كانت التصور هو
دول الخليج الى الان ومع الخطرين دول ومع
الخطرين دولي جاء قارئ جديد او اه تغير
مهم جدا هي رغبه الولايات المتحده في نفض
يدها من هموم المنطقه ومشاكلها والانتقال
يتطلع الى الاهتمام بقضايا اخرى في شرق
اسيا لمواجهه الخطر الصيني والروسي القصه
تكلمنا عن هذا الكلام معنى كده انه فيه
خطرين موجودين وفيه حليف بين
دول الخليج كانت تدور على حليف قوي تقدر
تستند عليه لتعويض الغياب الامريكي منهم
الحلفاء المطروحين تركيا باكستان مصر ودول
الاساسيين
باكستان عندها مشاكل كثيره باكستان دوله
مهمه استثمرت فيها دول الخليج عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات القصه ممكن نتكلم
عليها في وقت لاحق لكن ظروفها في الفتره
الماضيه والظروف السياسيه اللي عندها
والحدود المفتوحه والمشاكل اللي كانت حابه
انه هي تاثيرها مع ايران قالتها انهى
تعتدي حتى على المشاركه في التحالف للساعه
السعوديه ل تشكيله لخوض الحرب فيه اليمن
تركيا مش بس ان هي مش اه اه يعني متحمس
انها تساعد في الطرف المعادي للمعسكر اللي
تقف في السعوديه والامارات ومصر
صديق لكن صديق نتفق على نفسه مجهول بكثير
من مشاكله الكثيره جدا الداخليه والخارجيه
من بعد ثوره 25 يناير 2011
في المعادله لم يتوقف في المنطقه الدوله
قويه مؤثره غير اسرائيل مش ما هي قويه
تقريبا في تطابق في المصالح في هذه
المرحله يعني عدوهم هو عدوها
هؤلاء يعتبرون ايران هي العدو الاول
واسرائيل تعتبر ايران هي العدو الاول
هؤلاء يستشعرون خطر قاتل من جماعات
الاسلام السياسي واسرائيل منذ نشاتها والى
الان بتعتبر كل هذه الجماعات تحت اسماء
مختلفه عدو اساسي وبالتالي بقى فيه تلاقي
في المصالح تقدر تشوف شواهده في عشرات
اللقاءات وعشرات التصريحات والزيارات
السريه والعلنيه واضحه جدا
السبب الثاني اللي بيدفع الدول الخليج الى
اقامه علاقات قويه مع اسرائيل هو سبب
التقليدي المعروف انه تل ابيب في القلب
الى عقل وقلب
اه واشنطن
صحيح ان القصه دي فيها مبالغه لكن دائما
من عشره انه اسرائيل دوله مهمه جدا علشان
تنفذ الى دوائر صنع القرار في الولايات
المتحده ت بولي دول الخليج الصديقه
لواشنطن تحتاج الى صديق اخر لانه
هو علاقه اسرائيل اقوى كثير بواشنطن هي
عندها درايه اكبر على الوصول الى مراكز
صنع القرار بتكلفه اقل والاهم من كان
عندها القبول اذا صنع القرار ولدى الراي
العام الامريكي على عكس دول الخليج اللي
علاقتها بس وصناع القرار وبعد صناع القرار
فتقدر انه هي تساعدهم لحسم كثير من
القضايا اللي حصل حصل قضايا ساعدت فيها
اسرائيل كثير وقضايا ساعده اسرائيل ما
قدرت شيء لكن حاولت يعني مثلا نقدر نذكركم
سلام هو حضرتك مكان حد متابع مشكله شركه
موانئ دبي لما كانت عاوز تاخذ صفقه مجموعه
من الموانئ الامريكيه ورفضت السلطات
الامريكيه باعتبار ان هذا امر يعني لا يجب
ان يثقوا في في اسناده الى دوله عربيه
شايفين الاداء كده يعني امر السيادي يمثل
خطرا على امن الولايات المتحده من بين
الاطراف الرئيسه اللي دعمت
الحق او اهليه موانئ دبي في اطار هذه
الموانئ كانت شركه
اسم على ما اعتقد
الشركه الاسرائيليه وقتها وعملت عمليات
لوبين لانهما شركاء يعني فيه شراكه ما بين
موانئ دبي وهي الشركه ضخمه جدا عندك في كل
مكان في العالم ومع هذه الشركه
الاسرائيليه صحيح ان صفقه لم تتم لكن
اسرائيل حول
ايضا في قضيه كما لا يخفى على احد ان
اسرائيل
لعب دور كبير في محاوله احتواء في محاوله
احتواء ال غاضبا للراي العام الامريكي
ولصناع القرار اللي موجه ضد السعوديه
ثانيه وتكلم علنا في اهميه السعوديه
ودورها واهميتها الاستقرار المنطقه وكل
الكلام ده هل نجح يعني انجاح مش مهم انا
احاول واذا ما كانت نجحوا في المثالين دول
فاكيد ممكن ينجحوا امور اخرى
السبب الثالث وهو ايضا لم يعد سرا وهو انه
هذه الدول باتت مقتنعه ان اسرائيل
دوله موجوده في المنطقه وهي دوله متقدمه
جدا
وعندها التكنولوجيا تكاد تكون مش موجوده
بنفس الامكانيات اللي بتناسب دول المنطقه
عن دول اخرى كثيره امكانيات تتعلق بال
الاحتياجات اليوميه على التنميه والاقتصاد
زي مثلا صراعات الصحه لتحليه الماء الطاقه
الشمسيه في اي حاجه بكثير لكن الاهم من
كده هي الصناعات العسكريه
ولما بتتكلم عن الصناعات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه مابتتكلمش عم دبابات و طيارات
يعني كان ده موجود عند الدول الاكثر زي
روسيا والولايات المتحده
لكن بنتكلم على اجهزه التتبع والتجسس
والمراقبه اللي اه اسرائيل برعت فيها خلال
اكثر من يعني اه سبعين سنه في مواجهتها
المؤسفه والمخزيه ال اه ال الفلسطينيين
وبالتالي عندها خبرات متراكمه تستطيع
الدول الخليج ان تستفيد من هذه
التكنولوجيا في متابعه الجماعات المعارضه
او في الجماعات الارهابيه الى اخره
وبالتالي فيه اكثر من سابقه يعني عقدتها
ومن فتره مبكره دول الخليج في شراء هذه
الاسلحه المتقدمه او هذه البرامج المتقدمه
من اسرائيل لكل الازمه بدي على بعضها دول
الخليج تعتقد انها في حاجه الى اسرائيل
واسرائيل طبعا طبعا عندها الف السبب
يدعوها الى الترحيب والحرص على علاقه مع
دول الخليج ام الفيل المازق المازق ان
الكلام ده او هذه القناعات موجوده على
مستوى النخب الحاكمه في دول الخليج لكنها
مش موجوده على مستوى القاعده الشعبيه
وبالتالي من الصعب جدا على قاده هذه الدول
ان يصارحوا شعوبهم باهميه علاقه علنيه
ومفتوحه مع اسرائيل
وما فيش حل ما قدروش الوجهه الشعوب ولا
يقول لها بصراحه حقيقه ما يجري في الغرف
المغلقه الا بشرط واحد ان اسرائيل تساعدهم
وتقطع نصف الطريق تحفظ ماء وجههم واه تسعى
او تقبل
بالحدود الدنيا من سلام مع الفلسطينيين
طيب وما مشكله اسرائيل انها تعمل السلام
مع الفلسطينيين
المشكله انه فيه تغيير كبير عند
الاسرائيليين قبل كده يعني من سبعه وستين
على الاقل طبعا من سبعه واربعين بس خلينا
نقول من سبعه وستين يعني بعد احتلال من
بعد الهزيمه العربيه امام اسرائيل في سبعه
وستين واحتلالها للاراضي العربيه كانت
اسرائيل بتقدم وتسعه صفه واحده اللي هو
الارض مقابل السلام ارجع لك ما ردكم العرب
في المقابل تعمل سلام وتطبيع مع اي
مداخلات في السنوات الاخيره ومع الضعف
الشريف اللي طرا على الدول العربيه مؤخرا
وخروج الدول الكثير من المعادله
اصبحت اسرائيل غير مستعده لقبول معادلته
الوقت انه الارض معانا والسلام اللي احنا
ناخذ من الدول العربيه هو مقابل التعاون
مع اسرائيل القويه وانا بقول وده مش
استنتاج الى تصريحات رسميه لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
قال لي احنا مش محتاجين نقدم اي تنازلات
الى العرب ولا الى اي صفقات اه اه يعني اه
نتنازل بموجبها على اي م ما نعتقد مما
يعتقد انه هو حقوق لي ولكنها تحالفها يقوم
على قيمه اسرائيل ابريل فاليو قيمه
اسرائيل الماليه
والد في الد في الماليه وفي الدفاع
والاستخبارات والتكنولوجيا التصريح الرسمي
وبالتالي انا اعمل تحالف مع العرب في
مقابل نقدم لهم خدماتي في كل هذه القطاعات
الى اسرائيل متفوقه فيها يترتب على كده ان
القاعده الانتخاب اللي بتدعم
اليوم ممكن يعني يسقط في الانتخابات اللي
كان في قاعده بتاييده شايفه ان ما فيه
تقدم اي حاجه للفلسطينيين وبالتالي رفض
يقولوا الحلول المطروحه
اه هي الحلول المطروحه رافضين حل الدولتين
وحل الدوله الواحده حل الدولتين يعني فيه
صرت المثل انه الاسرائيليين يرجعوا للحدود
ما قبل سبعه وستين ويبقى الفلسطينيين
تقيموا دوله اخرى على حدود اه ما قبل سبعه
وستين يعني حدودهم اللي هي الضفه الغربيه
والقدس الشرقيه وغزه في صرت مغير المثلث
انه ال اسرائيل
دوله وفلسطين دوله مساله مساحه اقل من
حدود مقابل سبعه وستين بعدما اسرائيل
توغلت في اراضي الضفه الغربيه في القدس
الشرقيه ويحاول واراده الفلسطينيين
ب اه اه باقل من حقوقهم لا وزير ولا يعني
مش عاوزين حل الدولتين هل الدوله كان عنده
اجراء واحد وهو انه
في مجموعه ما زالت في اسرائيل والتي حل
الدولتين ليس حبا في الفلسطينيين ولا حبا
في السلام ولكن حبا في انه يحتفظ دوله فيه
اغلبيه يهوديه بدون اي مرات في المستقبل
يعني حل الدولتين في اسرائيل سواء في حرب
سبعه وستين او اكثر شويه واعتبر الاغلبيه
في الى اليهود وموجود طبعا الفلسطينيين ال
او عرب ثمانيه واربعين اللي عددهم واحد
وثمانيه من عشره مليون لكن ان تضل
الاغلبيه الى الاسرائيليين وما فيش مشكله
بقى فيه ناس بتايد الحل الثاني الحل
الثاني اللي هو حل الدوله الواحده حل
الدوله الوحده معناها ان اسرائيل وتضم
القدس الشرقيه وتضم معها ال ال اه الضفه
الغربيه
وممكن غزه وبلاش غزه يشوفوا لها حل ثاني
في المقابل ان نقول للفلسطينيين دول
انا لست الدوله فيها اه يعني قوميتين
واقول وبيحصل على
حقوق المواطنه او دوله ديمقراطيه واحده
وفى الحاله دى محدش يتكلم على الاراضي
والحدود ولا اي حاجه لكن المشكله في القصه
دي ببساطه طبعا فيها مشاكل كثير لكن
ببساطه ما تيجى تشوف
التوازن الديمغرافي يعني السكاني ما بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين ا تلاقي
المساله يمكن ان يوافق عليها الاسرائيليين
انه دائما عليه انه الاسرائيليين الان
وتقديرات الاسرائيليين بتقول ان عدد العرب
في المنطقه الواقعه ما بين نهر الاردن
والبحر المتوسط اللي بيتكلم على حوالي
طناشر ونص مليون حاجه زي كده
سته ونص يهودي وحوالي سته وثمانيه من عشره
فلسطيني يعني معنى كده الى الواقع الان
انه الان الكفه تميل الى الفلسطينيين لو
اصبحوا دوله واحده معناها انه تدريجيا بعد
سنه عشره عشرين هيكلهم اغلبيه في البرلمان
هو كمان مش بعيد ابدا لما يكون عندهم مش
مش بعيده منطقه لما يكون عندهم اغلبيه في
البرلمان
يكون رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي اسمه محمد
احمد محمود يعني شخصيه مسلمه وبكره تفقد
فكره الدوله اليهوديه فحواها وتفقد الفكره
يعني او تنسف الفكره من قدرها الحل الثالث
ايه الحل الثالث لحل الدوله وعلى حل
الدولتين واحتلت واحتلت وعملت على ان
كمواطن من الدرجه الثانيه ليسلك اي حقوق
ال حقوق المحتل ولا بالنسبه لل عرب ثمانيه
واربعين لهم اهليه كامله زي ما عمله بعد
ما عملوا قانون يهوديه الدوله اللي ب يحرم
على غير اليهود
التصوف في قرارات مصيريه بالنسبه
الاسرائيلي تبدا وضع مش ممكن يستمر لانه
في حاله استمرار
ان اسرائيل تصبح دوله قطر
يعني فصل عنصري تبقى عمل جنوب افريقيا
لقيت التسعينات والعشرات السنوات السابقه
دوله تقوم على التمييز العنصري وبالتالي
لا يمكن ابدا ان يكون عضو طبيعي في
المجتمع الدولي ولا تقدر تسوي صورتها
كدوله ديمقراطيه ولا دوله حريات اذا كل
الاختيارات الثلاثاء حتى الان اسرائيل
ايضا في مازق لكنه مازق الدوله القويه
اللي تقدر تدخل اي حل وتفرع الجميع لكن
الحلول قدمها حلول ملغومه ما بتفكر في ايه
بتفكر في حل رابع خامس يبدو وكانه من باب
الخيال العلمي مفرق لهم حلقه اخرى ان شاء
الله اشكركم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله
[موسيقى]